president Trump about to make a big trip
did you read about that sure you did
all right or who cares cookie
the reaction of the crowd again that's
the heat talking okay that's not about
Trump no this is true president Trump is
going to Japan to meet with the prime
minister and may play a round of golf
yeah
Horace Trump putted he's going to Japan
to play around to golf and he may meet
with the prime minister he's got that
priority yeah those goods for Trump
announced that very recently actually
over the weekend that he will release
over 3,000 classified files relating to
the Kennedy assassination yeah yeah yeah
Trump is releasing them spoiler alert
apparently Hillary did it
I always knew it
the latest rumor in Washington is that
Trump is looking for a replacement for
Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson yeah after hearing after
hearing the job entails constant trips
out of the country Melania volunteered
by the way I have to commend you on your
reaction to the setup that was really I
was like oh he's looking for a new
Secretary of State because oh I'm
telling you they don't care oh this is a
puzzler what's next code Melania Senator
John McCain is refusing refusing to come
out and label President Trump a draft
dodger refusing yeah
McCain says I prefer the term wartime
[ __ ]
Harvey Weinstein we didn't get to talk
about this we've been off the air for
two weeks yeah yeah as a baseball but
we're back now Harvey Weinstein just
finished a week-long stay at a rehab
clinic for sex addiction yeah apparently
he would have stayed longer but all the
other sex addicts thought Weinstein was
too creepy a couple ordered a package
from Amazon this is a true story and
included with their stuff was 65 pounds
of marijuana was only then that the
couple realized that they had
accidentally signed up for Amazon primo
it was pretty stupid uh-oh everyone's
okay I want to stress it or one's okay
but last Friday dr. Phil dr. Phil hit a
skateboarder with his car yeah dr. Phil
was overheard yelling quick somebody get
a real doctor
[Applause]
that's my entire dr. Phil impression as
him blowing up one end of his Mustang
huh uh gotta mention this an inmate is
suing his prison after he had an
erection for 91 hours
true story yeah yeah it's what prison
officials call hard time now folks
that's horrifying I'm gonna get a letter
from a dermatologist yeah yeah yeah well
you got up close and that thing right
there you should look at that yeah
you